كان من اشد المتحمسين لامتلاك السوفيتي
سلاحها النوويه واسهم في انتاج القنبله
الهيدروجينيه ثم تحول الى احد اكبر اعداء
السلاح النوويه ودفع ثمن كثيرا لاعلانه
ارائه فما هي قصه اندريس خروف الذي عرف
بابي القنبله الهيدروجينيه
ولد اندريس عام
1921 في موسكو ونشا ببيئه المهتمه بالفنون
والاداب والعلوم
كان مدرسا للفيزياء ومؤلفا لكتب العلميه
ومناهج مدرسيه كما كان عازفه بيانو محترف
الدروس الخاصه في المنزل لعده سنوات قبل
ان يلتحق بقسم الفيزياء بجامعه موسكو في
عام 1938
ولكن وبسببي تداعيات الحرب العالميه
الثانيه تم اجلاؤه وزملائه الى عشق اباد
المعروفه بتركمانستان اليوم لمتابعه
دراسته حيث تخرج عام 1942
بعد تخرجه عامل اندريه حطابا في مستوطنه
الريفيه مهجوره قبل ان يلتحق بمصنع
للذخيره عام
1942 حيث انتج عددا من الاختراعات في مجال
التحكم في الانتاج
الى موسكو ليتابع دراسته لنيل درجه
الدكتوراه ثم انتقل سخروف الى مدينه صاروخ
السريه في عام 1950 حيث لعب دورا رئيسيا
الى جانب زميله واستاذه تام بتطوير اول
قنبله هيدروجينيه سوريا
في الثاني والعشرين من نوفمبر عام
1955 تمكن العلماء سوريا من اجراء تجربه
ناجحه على اول قنبله هيدروجينيه لهم وهو
الانجاز الذي نسب الى اندريه ونال بفضله
العديد من التكريمات على مستوى بلده
اصبح اندريه احد المبادرين للعمل على
دراسه تفاعل النووي حراري وطرح فكره
التراكم المغناطيسيه وفكره ضغط الليزر
للحصول على تفاعل النووي حراري النبضيا
محكوم كما الف العديد من الاوراق البحريه
في علم الكونيات واوراق حول الجسيمات
الاوليه ونظريه المجال
مع الوقت ادرك اندريه خطوره سلاح النووي
على البشر فبدا يدعو الى وقف التجارب
والابحاث حول الاسلحه النوويه والتحق بركب
حركات الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان
ليتحول من باحث ومخترع للقنبله النوويه
الى معارض لها اما ما زاد الطين بالله فهو
المقال الذي نشره في عام
1968 والذي حمل عنوان تاملات في موضوع
التقدم والتعايش السلمي وحريه العقل
نشر اندريه مقالاته وارائه في صحف كبرى
وكان لها صدا كبيرا لدرجه انه طرد من
برامج الابحاث النوويه كما حصل على جائزه
نوبل للسلام في عام
لكن وبسبب متابعته لنشاطه المناهض لسلاح
النووي تم نفي اندريه دون محاكمه الى
مدينه جورجيا في عام
1980 حيثما كيف تحت مراقبه الشرطه
وتدهورت صحته كما قام باضرابات طويله عن
الطعام
في ديسمبر عام
1986 افرج عنهم ميخائيل غورباتشوف فعاد
الى موسكو ووصل العمل بمعهد ليبيديف وسميح
له بمواصله نشاطه العلميه حتى وفاته في
الرابعه عشر من ديسمبر عام
رحل اندريس خروف مع ذنب كبير حمله بسبب
تصميمه القنبله الهيدروجينيه لكنه ترك
اوراق علميه اخرى وبقايا معارك كبرى في
الدفاع عن المبادئ الاخلاقيه التي امن
انها لعل وعسى ان تشفع له من الم الضمير
الذي عاش معه طويل